ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello,
everybody.
My name is Arun Nagarajan, and
I'm with the Google Apps
Script Team.
JOHN MCGOWAN: My name is John
McGowan, and I'm a developer
on Google Drive.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
This session is Integrate
Google Drive
with Google Apps Script.
And we're really excited for
all of you to be here.
Google Drive is a storage and
collaboration platform with
millions of users with
billions of files.
In this session, you will
learn how to write
applications that provide
value to those users.
There are many ways to write
these applications, but today
we're going to focus on an
exciting platform called
Google Apps Script, which we
think is really an easy way to
get started, but also a powerful
way to deliver value
to these users.
And we're going to tell you this
story by focusing on two
integration scenarios.
The first one is having your
application available to the
user in the interface that
they're already used to--
drive.google.com.
Real easy to remember, probably
the home page for a
lot of folks that are living
in Google Drive.
This means being available in
the Create menu, and also in
the Open option for
a selected file.
And then the second part, which
really goes well with
the newly released service, is
the ability to access those
billions of files from
Google Apps Script.
So being able to access those
files-- write files, changing
permissions--
as the user from Google
Apps Script.
So those are the two things
we're going to show you.
But we think it's really
important to show you this
with a live demo.
So we're going to start off by
showing off a demo, and then
come back and deconstruct what
we did in a nice flow.
Yesterday at the keynote, you
heard our leaders tell you
that we have 25 million users
in the education space.
It's a really important
segment for us.
It's something that these users
are finding a lot of
value in already.
In the demo today, we're going
to-- we made up an application
called Quiz Manager.
And the idea is to provide a
little utility to teachers to
allow them to take what usually
is a roster in a
spreadsheet, and then being
able to turn that into
assigned assignments through a
Drive document, or a Google
Document, I should say.
Now that's what we
want to show you.
That's the demo we're
going to build you.
Some of the requirements that
you should keep in mind as
we're showing you this is that
it should be the whole life
cycle of the quiz that
we want to manage.
Being able to start from the
roster all the way to then
completing the quiz.
We want it to be supportive
of multiple file creation.
So one of the more painful
things sometimes is copying a
file 15 times, renaming it
appropriately, and sharing it
with the right people.
So we want to take that human
error and pain out of the
picture, and have it facilitate
the creation of
multiple files.
And we want it to be completely
integrated with the
Drive interface.
So the application itself has
very little UI by itself.
You work with it in Drive.
And we want to be built with
the easy-to-use platform
that's easy to tweak, upgrade
to what the new requirements
might be, and run
on the cloud.
So I don't have to, as a teacher
a an administrative
person at the school,
manage a lot of
different systems, right?
So let's go take a look.
All the code is available on
our system, on GitHub.
So don't have to worry about
getting access to the code.
So I'm going to switch over
to the demo laptop.
So here is Google Drive.
Everybody's very familiar
with this.
So like any good teacher,
there's a lot of different
applications that this teacher's
already installed.
What we want to do with this is
install a new application
into this and then be able to
do some interesting things
with the files in
Drive itself.
So now I'm going to assume the
role of that teacher, and I'll
play along as the teacher.
So the teacher recently got an
email saying, there's an
awesome new application that
you can install into your
Google Drive.
And it's really easy to install
and really easy to get
started, and it'll help me
with my quiz management.
So I'm going to click on the
link to get started.
It's going to show me a simple
welcome screen to install the
application.
I go ahead and install it--
a very standard, trusted screen
that tells me that this
is from Google, do you want to
install this application into
your Drive?
This one, this user's Drive
Create Assignment, and that
allows me to trust
that screen.
I've installed it.
Let me close that, go
back into Drive.
Refresh my Drive window.
And now we have a new option
available called Create
Assignment.
So it makes sense, as well, from
a teacher's perspective
on what it does.
So I'm going to say, let's
go ahead and create an
assignment.
So what's happening now is
that this application is
working against the user's
Drive and creating the
documents and the folder
structure necessary for the
document to exist.
So I'm going to hit
Close here.
Go back to my drive, and now I
have a new folder called New
Assignment.
I'll go within it, and I see
that there is now a couple of
files here of interest.
There is a roster, and
there's also a
template for quiz questions.
OK?
In order to facilitate the demo,
I've just kind of saved
a sample roster.
I'm going to copy and
paste that in.
And we've also come up with a
quiz we think is a really good
quiz to give to high
school students.
It's a standard Google
quiz, I think.
All right.
So what I have now is a
quiz, a roster, and I
think I'm good to go.
So now what I'll do is I'll
come here, and I'll hit
Publish Quiz.
And that's going to spin.
And in the meantime, I'm going
to switch over here.
On the right side of my screen,
I am now a student.
So that's my second persona.
And what's going to happen is
a new file just popped into
Jane's Drive.
She didn't have to go and
refresh anything.
This is the always online
collaborative aspect of Google
Drive coming into play.
And as far as the teacher's
concerned, the application's
finished for him or her.
And now there's a bunch more
files for the teacher to grade
and look at.
So let's go back to
being a student.
I am Jane.
I've come back in.
And OK, the first question
I know the answer to.
The next question
I think is 9.
This one--
that's kind of beyond me, so
I'm going to slack off, and
let's say that I'm just going
to go to a movie and
not solve this quiz.
In the meantime, the deadline
has passed.
The teacher decides now
to close the quiz.
No longer can you add
more content to it.
It's sort of like pencils
down, right?
That's what that button does.
And that's going to now spin,
and it's going to finish.
And the quiz is now closed,
according to the quiz manager.
Let's say Jane comes back, and
she's feeling all wise, and
she says, I don't know,
this is tricky.
And she tries to answer
the question anyway.
Google Drive--
Google Docs is going
to try to save it.
It's going to do its best to
save what it thinks it can
save automatically, but then
it realizes that the
permissions have been taken
away from the quiz.
So it's no longer a quiz where
the student can work on.
All she can do now is reload
this page, which will bring
her into her last save point.
So she at least got two
questions, and it's now in
View Only mode, right?
So now at this point, she can
look at the comments and the
grades that the teacher's
providing, but she can no
longer enter any content
into the quiz.
So that's what the whole
workflow is all about--
being able to start something,
and then as a student take the
quiz, and then come back in.
So all that code is available.
And what we're going to do now
is deconstruct what we just
showed you.
So what did we show you here?
So we were able to take a
classroom example of being
able to take a roster and
convert that into a set of
assigned documents
for the quiz.
We were able to work within the
Google Drive UI, as well.
So we were able to meet
that requirement.
And it was one click to publish
that assignment.
So we were able to take the
roster and the template that
was already there and then
assign that to the right
people with the right privileges
at the right time,
and then flip that back
and take it away.
And you'll also notice that I
actually used files in the
folder itself to act like
command runners.
So when I clicked on it, it knew
the context of where it
was and what it meant,
and operated on the
files in that folder.
So that's a little trick that
allows you to have little
executable-like links from
within a folder and do some
interesting things.
And you'll also notice that it
was the default action for
when I clicked on it, so
the default MIME type
associated with it.
Now there's a lot of
improvement ideas
here for the viewers.
We wanted to make sure that you
knew what else could be
done with this.
This is by no means a
finished product.
It's really a set of
principles that we
wanted to show you.
There's a lot of ways you
could monitor progress.
You could ask--
you could write a little
application to see when the
deadline's coming up and
alert the students.
Close the assignments
automatically on a timed trigger.
These are things that are
possible in Apps Script.
And also, having a nice
assignment dashboard.
When is the student actually
working on it?
Has she not even opened
the document?
Things like that.
So you're able to get history
and things like that from the
Drive service, which
is pretty useful.
The Drive API, I should say.
So now, that was the demo to
kind of show you what's
possible in the Google
Apps Script plus
Google Drive world.
Now let's take you through how
we built it and what some of
the technical salient points are
for this particular demo.
So we're going to show you
this in two parts.
So first, I'm going to quickly
introduce Google Apps Script.
And then, John's going to give
you more of the detailed
deep-dive on what we did
in Apps Script itself.
Then I'll talk about what was
really important in the
Google Drive SDK.
And then we'll bring it all
together at the end.
So the important thing about
Google Apps Script, I think,
that's really exciting to show
off is the fact that it is a
cloud-based JavaScript platform
that allows you to do
more with Google.
It allows you to take apps that
you already love, like
Gmail, Drive, Docs, Sites, and
then automate, integrate, and
extend those applications.
And you can do that beyond just
the Google APIs, as well.
We have the ability to call
external services, as well.
So I think that's really
important.
And the best part of it is that
you're able to write the
code in a browser.
So that's an actual screenshot
of the browser with a script
editor loaded up.
The URL is script.google.com.
You can try it on your Pixels.
It's really easy to remember,
really easy to get to.
And that actually in there is
a working example of an app
that could archive
a Gmail inbox.
There's no limits--
it's not limited to the first
hundred, or something like
that, so that will probably
time out in a large inbox.
But the idea is that it's really
easy to write this
JavaScript, and there are things
like auto-complete that
make you even more productive
and comfortable within this
environment.
The important thing that made
this all possible is the fact
that Google Apps Script apps
can be deployed as web
applications.
So that's the screenshot of
what the deployment screen
looks like.
That was announced last I/O, so
it's really exciting for us
to use this for some interesting
capabilities.
And what you essentially end up
doing is expose these web
endpoints for your
business logic.
And the business logic is what
John's going to talk about--
how we were able to take the
calls, and perform operations
on the user's Drive.
We were able to also run the
application to execute as the
user, rather than the developer
that wrote it.
That's really important, because
we're trying to save
to the user's Drive, not
the developer's Drive.
So that authorization part is
really taken care of for you.
And you're able to-- if you have
Google Apps for Education
or Google Apps for Business,
you can restrict the
application to be only available
to people within
your organization.
So that's actually a really nice
feature of Google Apps
Script to restrict that
access pretty easily.
And from a developer standpoint,
all you need to do
is implement a method called
doGet, which is very familiar
for folks that have done Java
servlet programming, to
execute the logic that you need,
receive the context that
you need, and then return the
HTML, or any content you want
to return back.
Really straightforward
to do this.
So now let's step back
and look at the
Drive SDK bits of this.
The Google Drive SDK allows you
to integrate deeply within
the Google Drive UI.
So it allows you to show your
application within the Create
menu and the Open option.
You do that by defining
the metadata in
the Developer Console.
So that's a one-time option,
a process that's a bit of a
different console than you're
normally used to.
It's
developers.google.com/console.
Real easy to find once
you're there.
And then I'll talk you through
what the settings you need to
set up are.
Then you write the web
application, which we showed
you, to receive the context
and perform the logic.
And then at the very end of it,
how does the user get your
application?
In our example, we installed
it by visiting a link, by
requesting the drive.install
OAuth scope.
You can also have your
application available in the
Chrome Web Store, which
is really great for
discoverability, reviews,
having more videos and
screenshots of what your app
does and looks like.
So that's actually really
powerful, as well.
For our demo, it's a lot easier
to just email a link
and showcase that capability.
But I urge you to submit to
the Chrome Web Store for
really commonly used
applications.
So what is the lifecycle of
the app that we want to
demonstrate today?
It takes the click from the
Drive UI integration point and
the Create in the Open option,
invokes a web app with a
parameter called "state." Then
App Script kicks off its
execution of the business logic,
and then uses the Drive
App API in JavaScript to read
and write to the user's Drive.
OK?
So I'm going to talk about the
top part, and John's going to
cover the bottom part, which is
the JavaScript API that we
talked about.
So this kind of explains how
Google Drive SDK and the
Google Apps Script work
side-by-side.
So let's go a little deeper into
the Drive SDK and talk
about all the different settings
that are important.
The first thing you need to
do is enable the Drive SDK
Service in the Developer
Console.
Real easy to find it.
Just look for the Drive icon,
and it's Drive SDK.
Flip it on, and then you'll
have a new panel
on the bottom left.
That has a lot of settings.
It's really powerful in how
well you can brand your
application for mobile support,
for all the different
resolutions that we support.
But really, the important ones
that you have to remember to
deal with are the Open URL.
So your app has to open at least
one type of document.
That's a requirement.
In our example, notice that the
URL is script.google.com,
because we published
an App Script app.
You can register default MIME
types that your application is
associated with.
And that's the trick that we
used to have our apps open
when you click on that icon,
that little floral
icon that we had.
And you can make up your
own MIME types.
This is something that you're
able to define ad hoc and
respond to those.
And you can also have the Create
With option available.
So again, notice the URL is
script.google.com, followed by
your deployed URL.
So that's really important.
So those are three things that
you have to get right.
The others are more about
branding and the images and
things like that.
So what are the actions
that these URLs
receive that we showed?
They get URL-encoded
JSON strings.
That's what a state parameter
looks like.
It's actually pretty
self-explanatory to see that
it's the folder ID, what type
of action it is, and then a
user identifier.
So in that case, it's saying the
app-- the user requested
the Create action while
in that folder.
So you can actually get the
context of which folder the
users is in, so you could do
some nested things, as well,
if you wanted do.
And then the Open option tells
you, OK, which files did the
user want to open?
And you notice that
that's an array.
So if you allow the application
to, it'll let the
user select multiple options,
and then open that.
So in our case, since we're
executing commands, it doesn't
make sense to have multiple
selected.
So we only have one available.
There's a third type of
parameter called Import, which
we won't talk about here.
But that allows you to take
pre-defined types and convert
them, if you wanted, in
your application.
Now let's talk about from
a user standpoint.
This is what the user saw when
they visited the link.
In fact, in this example, I have
a couple of additional
scopes requested.
But in our example, it's just
add to Google Drive.
Very easy and simple screen that
users are used to from
installing applications.
And as long the user clicks on
Allow Access, your app is now
linked to the user's Drive.
Now what's cool about installing
applications to
Drive is that it's not like your
desktop world or mobile
world where you're downloading
binaries onto your machine.
You're essentially linking two
web applications together, one
being the user's Google Drive,
the other being your web
application.
And Google in the middle
mediating that, and ensuring
that everything is
done securely and
appropriately, right?
So that's really nice in that
you're installing a
cloud-based application
is really linking
the domains and whatnot.
And then one nice bonus is that
you can actually have
your application be
mobile-friendly.
So if you check that option,
it'll in fact allow the user--
the teacher, in this case-- to
kick off the Create Assignment
option from their Android
phone or smartphone.
So they're able to very
easily do this.
It'll have the same parameters
passed in, and then it'll
actually only work with the
Open option for now.
The Create option is
not supported.
But that's a nice little thing
you should do to your
applications if you have a
simple enough web app.
So what we just saw so far
is, how do you make your
application available within
the Google Drive UI?
What John's going to now do is
talk about how do we take that
invocation and then do the
business logic behind it to
create the files.
JOHN MCGOWAN: Thank you, Arun.
So at this point, I want
to do a quick overview.
Arun talked about Drive SDK, and
what it looks like for a
developer to integrate an
application with the Drive UI.
And also, what it looks like
for a user to install an
application within
the Drive UI.
I'm going to talk about a new
Drive service that we
announced this week that really
just integrates with
the user's files within Drive.
We created a new service for
a variety of reasons.
If you remember, we had a
Docs List API before.
But with the new service, we
built it on top of the Drive
API that we launched
last year.
And this allowed us to provide
a bunch of new features,
including new search
functionality that we couldn't
provide in the old API.
This allows us to do searches
on the file's metadata and
MIME types and stuff like that,
rather than just the
document's content or title.
We also thought about how
certain processes was very
complicated, such as getting a
collection of files or folders.
So we added iterators in order
to make retrieving collections
of files and folders much
easier to do and
much simpler to code.
I'll give you guys a code demo
of this later in the
presentation.
Since we are providing a new
service, we decided to add
some new features, as well.
One of the top three features
that were requested in the
Docs List API was to change
the ownership
of a file or a folder.
So we've added that into
this new service.
And I'm really excited to see
what you guys are going to be
doing with this--
the whole service, in general.
But I'll get into that more.
Also, another feature that we
did, since we were focusing on
sharing already, is we also
added the ability to change
the default sharing settings
of a document.
So now you can share a document
to an entire domain,
or publicly for anyone to view
or edit or comment on.
So what does this look like?
We made it a one-line change to
change the default sharing
visibility of a file.
So this one line, it
will take the quiz
template from Arun's demo.
We take the template of the
quiz, and we can share it to
anyone who has a link so they
can view it, and make a copy
of it if they wish.
So you can do the same thing
through the Drive UI, and it
takes two parameters.
One is the scope of people
that have access to the
document, and the other is the
permission that they have.
And this is how it relates to
the Google Drive UI, as well.
And again, I spoke about the
iterators in order to make it
easier to retrieve files
and folders.
Before, you had to deal with
indexing and page tokens.
Now, it only takes a couple
lines of code in order to
retrieve all the files and
folders of a document.
Or in this case, we're
getting a quiz for a
student and moving it.
So we just pull it out of all
of the folders that it's
currently in.
And this is just a
five-line change.
At this point, I'd like to show
you a quick demo of the
code in action.
And since we're all students
of life, it's going to
continue being a demo of
student versus teacher.
Now I have this code
here, and it's not
production-level code.
It's just going to be
a quick code demo.
What it's going to do is it's
going to create a folder for a
student, make a copy of our quiz
template, copy that into
the folder, and then share
it with our student.
So at the beginning,
it's very simple.
All that we do is we get the
quiz template, and this is the
same as our old API.
And then we share it publicly
for anyone who has a link so
they can view it, make
a copy of it.
Finally, we make a copy of
it, calling it quiz 2.0.
You know, everything
online is 2.0.
I heard one giggle.
So we create a folder for
our student, JerryBob.
He was my favorite student.
And at this point, we're going
to take all the parents of our
quiz so that we can move the
quiz into JerryBob's folder.
These four lines will
remove the quiz from
whatever folder it's in.
When you make a copy of a
document, it defaults in the
same folder as the original
document.
So we're just trying to move
it out of those folders.
And then this last line
will add the quiz
to JerryBob's folder.
Finally, we share the folder
with JerryBob.
And it will propagate down to
any documents within the
folder, so JerryBob will have
edit access for the folder,
and the files within it.
And in order to prevent
cheating--
because JerryBob likes to talk
with Jimmy, sits right next to
him in class.
Anyways, we make sure that he's
not able to share the
document, as well.
This is a new function that
we've also added.
So--
oops.
Actually, I wanted
to run that.
So I'm going to go ahead and
run this so you can see the
files that it creates.
And obviously, it's running
in the bar up here.
I didn't install this app.
I'm just running it within
the script as a demo.
Obviously, you can create
an application that does
all this for you.
So we have our assignment
templates over here, and you
can see the quiz template
is shared with
anyone who has the link.
And they can view it,
just as we wanted.
And then here's JerryBob's
folder, which is shared.
And I'm going to go in and
show you that quiz 2.0 is
shared with JerryBob.
So here he is.
He can edit.
And also, only the owner can
change the permissions.
Great.
Moving on, I mentioned that we
have more complicated search
functionality.
Before, you could only search on
title, or what the contents
of a document, or some
high-level searches.
But now we've add-- since we're
built on top of the
Drive API, we get all
that feature.
So you can now search on
the file's metadata.
You can search for
the date the file
was created or modified.
And also, get a collection of
all the files a specific user
has access to.
Obviously, you can also combine
these together to get
very granular searches and get
just the files you want.
There are few things to note
with the new service.
One of the things is we no
longer expose email addresses.
This is due to privacy
concerns.
You can still add editors and
viewers to documents using
their email address, and you
can also get what kind of
access a specific user has
to documents, as well.
And once again, since this was
built on the Drive API, we are
able to offer a bunch of other
features that we didn't have
time to talk about in our
presentation today.
But we also--
because it's also built on
Google Apps Script, we were
able to take care of all the
authorization flows for you,
as Arun demoed earlier.
And it's all built into the
cloud, so you can code on it
wherever you want.
With our new Pixel you can do
this out in the grass, get
yourself a tan.
One thing to point out is
Arun's demo was actually
originally written with
the old Docs List API.
And it's actually really easy to
migrate from the old API to
the new Drive service,
as well.
I went and migrated it over out
in the sun, and as you can
tell, I didn't get
a very good tan.
So, it was a little too easy,
but we're really excited to
see what you guys are going to
do with the new Drive SDK and
Google Apps Script, and
this new service,
and putting it together.
So hopefully you guys can go out
and get a tan, as well, as
you build some pretty
cool apps.
We look forward to hearing what
feedback you guys have on
this presentation.
But at this point, we are open
to taking your questions.
We have two microphones
in the center here.
Once again, this is Arun.
My name's John.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
On the transfer ownership of the
documents, is there a way
to transfer ownership to public
Gmail accounts and
import documents from a
public Gmail account?
JOHN MCGOWAN: It will follow the
sharing permissions that
you can do through the UI.
So if you can do it through the
Drive UI, you can also do
it through the new Drive
service, as well.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's consistent
with what you're
able to do in the UI.
So if your domain allows your
documents to be shared outside
of your domain--
to, like, Gmail accounts--
then you should be able to do
it with the API, as well.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
you associate files
through MIME types.
What if another app also
registers for that MIME type?
Can you prevent them from
opening your file?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The user
ultimately wins.
Where is the Chrome book?
Here.
So the user is able to go into
the Manage Apps setting, and
then decide what
the default is.
So I don't know which gets the
default option, but the user
ultimately can decide.
AUDIENCE: But you
cannot prevent--
the user has control?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: The
user has control.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is, I was
in the session with Forms
and Apps Script as well.
Is there any cross,
interoperability between the two?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Well, not directly.
But it all runs with
the same ecosystem
of Google Apps Script.
So you could conceivably write
an app that you're able to
have a icon in the Create option
that, when you click on
it, creates five new
Google forms.
So you're able to script weaving
all the different APIs
together, and build some
interesting workflows just
like you describe.
AUDIENCE: Could you even
do it the other
way, where the form--
you can attach maybe an
assignment to the form and
have that go into Drive?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'd have to
think about that a little bit.
Maybe you could chat in
the Office Hours?
But you'd have to manage
that linking yourself.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [? Devesh ?]
[? Pramani ?] from
[? Cloud Coach. ?]
I have a couple of questions.
First, when you're copying a
document using the APIs, is
there any way to copy the script
associated with the
document, like a spreadsheet?
When I copy a spreadsheet
through an API, the script
doesn't get copied.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's only the document
you copy.
The script doesn't get copied.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
I wasn't familiar-- is that only
for documents, or also
for spreadsheets?
AUDIENCE: Spreadsheet,
sites, everything.
Whenever I do copy site
or copy documents--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So copying from
the UI is copying the
scripts, but not the--
AUDIENCE: I'm using APIs
to copy spreadsheet or
document the site.
Only the content gets
copied, except the
script doesn't get copied.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
We'll have to investigate
that.
AUDIENCE: Second thing is about
performance of Apps Script.
Is there anything that you have
standard best practices
by which we can optimize
performance?
Because as data starts
increasing with associated
spreadsheet, it starts
degrading.
And there is--
is there a best practice that
you have, or something?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So, yeah,
there's actually a section on
our website about how
do you optimize
spreadsheet-based access.
There's batch access
and batch write.
At some point, you may even
exceed those thresholds.
A spreadsheet's not
a database.
And we have other products like
Fusion Table and BigQuery
that solve the millions
of rows problem.
So there's a fine line
there somewhere.
But for hundreds of rows, even
thousands of rows, I've seen
if you use the batch access
methods that we have, you're
able to get decent
performance.
And there's also caching
available.
So if you could prevent from
going back into the
spreadsheet every 10 minutes, or
whatever the threshold is,
that might also help
performance.
The caching service.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about finding the
scripts that I create.
Like, I've created scripts for
documents before, and I have
to open the document and
then go to Script
Manager to find them.
With these that aren't
necessary linked to a
particular document, will they
just show up in my Drive list?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a really
good question.
So scripts, depending on how
you create them, are
first-class items in Drive.
So if you create them from the
Create menu here, or go to
script.google.com, they're
considered top-level scripts.
And they will show up here,
and you can share them and
move them into a folder just
like any other file.
But if they are within a
spreadsheet or within a
document, think of it
almost like an image
embedded in that document.
So it kind of gets encapsulated
within the
document, and you share it
with the document itself.
It's not a separate item.
It's called container-bound
scripts is the term we use.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is, can documents
created with the Drive SDK or
Apps Script scripts
that you make be
made available offline?
JOHN MCGOWAN: Yes.
They can be made available
offline, but you can't edit
them offline--
unless it's like a
Google document
that has offline enabled.
AUDIENCE: So it's just
a read-only view?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Well, it should
manage what the sync
tool already does.
So I'll have to think
about the one.
That's a really interesting
question.
Come by the Office Hours
right after this.
AUDIENCE: We can
give that a try
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We'll
do a quick test.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You said that you'd
removed the email addresses
from the API.
So is there any way to get a
list of documents that a user
has access to?
Or if you've got a document, get
the list of users who have
access to that document?
JOHN MCGOWAN: You can get a list
of documents that a user
has access to using the
search functionality.
However, at this point, you
can't get a list of email
addresses that have access
to a document.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if I know a particular
document, I can't see who else
has access to that?
JOHN MCGOWAN: Correct
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You can ask--
if you also know an email
address, and you know the
document, you could say, does
this person have access?
But that's about it.
You cannot just get a list of
all email addresses against
the document.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is that even in Google
Apps for Business, if
the document is--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
correct.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Regarding the other question
about searching for your
script files--
when you have hundreds of
documents, is there any way to
look into just the script
files you have?
Because it's complicated, like
scrolling down between all the
documents to find just
the script ones.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
That's a good idea--
write a script to find
all your scripts.
I don't know what we have
that would solve that.
JOHN MCGOWAN: You should be able
to do searches based on
script in the advance search
functionality.
I'm not sure if--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
There's no script there.
JOHN MCGOWAN: There is
no script there.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
JOHN MCGOWAN: All right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Point taken.
But you could--
AUDIENCE: You can write scripts
in folders now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
what I do.
JOHN MCGOWAN: OK, cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Regarding the Drive search, did
wildcards make it into the
new version?
JOHN MCGOWAN: We did update
the Drive API with this.
But since it's based on the
Drive API, we offer the same
search functionality
as the Drive API.
AUDIENCE: But wildcards
are not in?
JOHN MCGOWAN: I'm not
entirely sure.
I think the answer is no.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Not
at this point.
JOHN MCGOWAN: Not
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, good afternoon.
Is there access to the version
control functionality that's
inside documents and
spreadsheets by the SDK?
JOHN MCGOWAN: The new
Drive service?
AUDIENCE: The versioning
inside documents.
So one of the things I'm trying
to do is try to version
lock aspects of the document,
or a document in a certain
amount of time.
I've not managed to
find any way of
looking into the versions.
JOHN MCGOWAN: OK.
At this point, we don't support
that in the Drive
service that we just launched
for Apps Script.
I think you can get the
change log using
the Drive API, though.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: That's only for
library files, though.
But the Google Docs revision
history isn't exposed in any
API right now.
But we know that we're bad
for doing that, and--
AUDIENCE: You're bad, you say?
He's bad.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's the
guy you want to convince.
AUDIENCE: Currently, we are
figuring out ways of making
ourselves feel less
bad about that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Not solving
the problem, just
feeling less bad.
AUDIENCE: Just version control
is a big deal for legal audit
trail for a lot of enterprises,
yeah?
Thanks.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think
to that earlier
question, if you type--
or, going into Google Drive, and
Create With, I think you
can choose Apps Script to bring
up your app scripts.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Also, with the Doc
List, are we going to-- you're
going to deprecate that
over a period of time?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yep.
So Docs List is deprecated.
There's no sort of date
announced at this point where
that will be turned off.
But it's standard deprecation
policy, so we have an
alternative now in Drive App.
So we encourage you
to shift over.
And like John said, it
was actually a very
straightforward exercise.
We've taken care to ensure
that the APIs are pretty
consistent.
So it should be sort of an
afternoon type thing.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello, again.
Regarding revision history, is
there any roadmap to have
Drive be involved with Vault?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good question.
I don't have any updates
on that.
That's a good question.
Do you know?
JOHN MCGOWAN: I do not know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Question
about delegation.
Will it support delegation, the
Drive API, in Apps Script
eventually?
JOHN MCGOWAN: That's something
that we're working on in Drive
API that we know about.
So right now, Drive API
doesn't support it.
So we can't support it with
the Drive service, either,
since we're built
on top of them.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So one of the
things you could do with Apps
Script is that you could run
it as the developer.
And then the developer has admin
rights, some of those
things will come through.
But what is difficult is the
hybrid models run partially as
the user, and run partially
as the administrator.
Those are the situations
that become difficult.
But if you think about building
your application,
knowing that there's
two options--
run as the developer, and
run as the user--
you can actually build most use
cases through if you just
kind of think through
that with that lens.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Now what I've done, but not
with Apps Script, is
delegation.
Like, you can install the
scope in the domain.
And then you can act like
an administrator.
You are--
the user is an administrator,
but can't specify which user
to pretend to be.
That's something that you are
considering integrating into
Apps Script?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We're
looking into it.
No updates at this point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This might be slightly off
topic, but I was curious if
we're going to have any options
to export in native
format from Drive coming
anytime soon?
I mean, I realize that
Word export is--
or, Microsoft exports and Open
Doc are pretty high fidelity.
But there's a lot of--
in my situation, there's a lot
of users who are transferring
data from one account to
another, and they end up
exporting it and converting
it, and uploading it and
converting it to a different
account via take out or via
the Drive interface.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So
theoretically, you could build
that with the set owner API.
So you could theoretically
say, run a script that
iterates through all my files
and sets the owner to another
Google account.
AUDIENCE: As long as you're--
when you're in Google
Apps, though.
I meant Google Apps Education.
And whenever we tried
to do that to
get out of the domain--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Education
has that limitation.
AUDIENCE: --it will
[INAUDIBLE].
So we have people leaving--
for example, seniors graduating
high school.
And we're forcing them to export
everything and then
giving them instructions to
make a new Google Gmail
account or at their university
to upload everything, because
they can't-- it just comes to
a standstill when you try to
script out an export--
or, excuse me, an
owner change.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
Yeah, I think that's a document
setting with Google
Apps for Education.
But we'll look into
how to solve this.
AUDIENCE: Just a suggestion.
Thank you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You can make
a copy, that's right.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Will we ever be able to share
scripts across domains?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You
can share scripts
across domains already.
It's just like any other file.
So what you can do is--
it's easy enough to--
AUDIENCE: But to
a whole domain.
So for example, I want to share
this script to this
whole domain.
Everybody from this domain that
is not mine can't access
the script.
So I know I can do
it specifically
to get to one person.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I see.
AUDIENCE: The chances are that
you can do that already.
But what's confusing about it
is that if you share an item
with a very large group of
people, like your whole
domain, you need to publish a
link that they can click.
It won't automatically show up
in their Drives until they go
and look at the file.
And that's done to stop hacks
and spam on every single thing
available to the domain.
But if you've got the internal
website, for example, you
could say, hey everybody who
wants to do this, click this
link, and then you'll
be able to see this
script in Google Drive.
So just set the settings so
that it's shared in your
domain and publish
a link to it.
And it'll just work.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So I
think we have time
for one more question.
We will be at the Office
Hours right after this.
AUDIENCE: This isn't as much
of a question, Arun, but I
just wanted to +1 what Doug
said very strongly.
We have the same kind of a
situation at the University of
Minnesota where we're
trying to move
people between domains.
We have five different campus
accounts, like domains.
And we'd love to just update
the metadata on your end to
push them all into one domain.
But yeah, find and replace
across all of Google for one
email address for a different
email address.
The left hand side's the same.
The right hand side changes a
little bit, a few characters.
And then everybody would
be super happy.
JOHN MCGOWAN: Got it.
So this is--
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's because like you
guys showed you can make
it where you can
share something
with that whole domain.
Well, we've got some things that
now are across campuses--
between multiple campuses-- and
then you try to share it
with the whole domain, and it's
like, I shared it with
the whole domain--
oh, except for all the
people in Duluth.
That's 30,000 people.
So I tried to think of like,
could I make an All at Duluth,
and share with that, too.
But then it doesn't
really work well.
It would show up nowhere until
they would click a link, and
stuff like that, to be able to
see the thing on their side.
And it could be much easier to
have everybody all in one
organization.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Understood.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
Thank you so much for
all the questions.
And hope you enjoyed it.
JOHN MCGOWAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]